bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
8 the deadly a stress eravamo rimasti
che prima eravamo arrivati all'acqua
all'acquario fanta che avete fatto
notare che che 8 de deux un polipo come
come se ne fosse accorto comunque ai
ragazzi ci siamo vediamo se mi ricordo
tipo come ci si va a perfetto devo
ricordarmi da tv come riprendere
confidenza dei comandi che sono un po
per fegan king io ti amo donne questo è
il mio modo di mostrarti il mio amore
per te tesoro mio allora che facciamo
finta di nulla andiamo avanti noi perché
sennò chi cazzo sono questi qualcosa ad
ora di pesce i biologi marini conoscono
un pesce quando ne vedono uno stai
attento a chi è un polipo colle ma tu
vuoi dirmi che ci vogliono i biologi
marini per capire che 8 ed è un cazzo di
polipo signora sono un polipo mia del
dirmi di cambiano che almeno lei mi
dicono che mi scusi se lo palpata va beh
quella faccia da parte del piano
presenta io io passo davanti agli altri
perché sono un po lì poi nessuno si
accorge di me ecco perché ci siamo
ragazze perfetto buongiorno senta mi mi
darebbe un biglietto per l'acquario da
eve sono sono qui allora vetro di
rispondermi perché altrimenti suo
tentacolo stato vedere in filo a
rispondevi cazzo dobbiamo riuscire a
fare anno perfetto fatto di gruppo
sì siamo ragazzi dobbiamo trovare devo
trovare la mia famiglia mia moglie è
entrata lì dentro perché vabbè ma io la
seguo nel dubbio chi se ne fotte dove
siamo che bello non ci voglio che non ci
voglio credere
ci vogliono acchiappa la talpa fatto da
8 dai trovano funzioneranno veramente
non ci voglio credere
pazzini vero funziona amiche ragazzi
avete mai visto un po di può giocare ad
acchiapparla talpa anzi alla chiappa al
pesce perché da oggi si e poi ragazzi
sta giocando sai come cazzo fa giocare
se guarda dall'altra parte spiegata me
la posso fare
guardali guardalinee acidità che bravura
che professionismo minchia manco mia
nonna gioca così bene abbiate pazienza
ho vinto qualcosa non so cosa ho vinto
ma ho vinto perché sono esageratamente
forte ho trovato cos'è sta roba
ho trovato un serpente di gomma devo
dare la mia mantieni guarda chiara che
cosa ho vinto te lo regalo piano il
nostro quarantesimo anniversario non
sono romantico ragazzi ma quale uomo
regala a sua moglie un serpente di gomma
per l'anniversario
io sì che son romantico cazzo devo farne
assolutamente altri perché sta cosa mi
ha preso troppo cos'è cos'è sta roba
a questo sono un po sta che ce la faccio
mai così il fenomeno è fenomeno cazzo
fosse così facile nonostante serventi di
gomma tesoro visto che ti amo così tanto
quel simbolo del mio amore come poi
gettarlo via così prego accetta questa
lucertola in dono perché io ti amo se
grande mi ama ancora meno male allora
ragazzi abbiamo trovato la lucertola
dobbiamo trovare casa a perfetto
giochiamo a baggio chiama basket perché
sono un fenomeno anche a questo io vi
vorrei far notare il demente che sta
tirando la palla se centrasse una cazzo
di volta al canestro
vabbè ma io ho visto che sono
professionista lo farò girato all
indietro ma io ti ho detto passi da era
più o meno lì è uscito di pochissimo ten
e secondo tiro incredibile
mamma mia che che fenomeno che è
fenomeno del basket ce ne fosse una che
come ho fatto a riprenderla st palla
guarda lo guarda lo guarda ho beccato la
possiamo fare non è così di niente
continua a peccare costantemente l'altro
tizio di fianco fa senti poi entrò nel
canestro vale perfetto sono gli sono
inchieste cazzo aiuto amore amore
prendimi prendi una pala cazzo mi sono
incastrato a ragazzi ho trovato la
tattica giusta che non pensavo io sono
nato per questo cazzo di gioco me lo
dicevano tutti da piccolo sei bravissimo
a giocare a basket ma io non gli ho mai
ascoltati ma lo sapevo in fondo grande
cose sono un fenomeno ragazzi sono un
fenomeno non c'è bisogno come lo diciate
lusso grazie grazie a tutti come lo so
che sono un fenomeno lo sappiamo già non
ce n'è bisogno ecco mare questo per te
perfetto ragazzi perfetto la sto
conquistando ragazzi e gioco del
martello dovrei essere un fenomeno in
teoria sono note potevo compare mai così
mica mi sto stancando io
vai vai se la piazza grande cazzo sono
troppo forte è lazio come butta sono mi
presento sono non solo un po li posso
giocare contro di lui veramente
aspettate un attimo posso veramente
giocare contro sto tizio ci fosse
mischia ragazzi avete mai visto un
polipo giocherà d'occhio il sul tavolo
da oggi si no cazzo cazzo ferma ferro ok
non penso allora vogliamo mettere la
scommessa dalla mia moglie mi sta
guardando band se mi fa fare una figura
di merda le tira un cazzotto di quelli
casa
su carta su carta su carta
non so se è chiaro sucate voli dal nord
atlantico che questo qui mi sta sul culo
devo farne un'altra la cosa che mi piace
di più di sti giochi e quando si gioca
pulito senza trasgredire le regole e io
sono un giocatore che non trasgredisce
le regole evince in modo corretto o
vinta in qualcosa da ridire sei scarso
per ragazzi voglio provare una cosa
incredibile che non mi riuscirà mai ma
voglio farlo guarda lo riguardano gli si
apre st tiro si appresta al tiro
cazzo
ma va a far con no non mi piacevo di
provare quale come si sa ma dove cazzo
andata ragazzi sta diventando un casino
io ve lo dico ci provo
non so che cosa devo fare in questo
centrale buco guardali nicchia che
ribelli sono troppo non c'e non c'e ne
vuol presente una ranocchia meglio che
me ne manchi uno che non ho capito ma
nicolini manca solo tifo e a questo non
ho ancora fatto cos'è strisci tos
agevole andremo a lanciare i pesci
devono già di pesci perfetto dove non
c'è di pesci dove allora senti perché
dato sono pesci vivi neanche pesci figli
ma non importa
ho vinto hanno dovuto sfondare tutto
perfetto allora ce la posso fare non è
così difficile
cazzo che mira di merda ragazzi ce la
posso fare ce la posso fare guarda mamma
mia figlia e killer vaccaia guardali
come vince guardali sono un grandissimo
giocatore
mamma mia mi sono fatto anche una doccia
gratis ed è l'ultimo flash e cazzo fai
così ci abbiamo messo anni per prenderlo
a queste perde amore mio
e con questo io ti dichiaro il mio amore
eterno
è il caso anche se è successo a perfetto
se si è bucata un qualcosa cosa avete
combinato bambini
devo fare è che se successo devo buttare
sta roba in mezzo perché sono delfino
[ __ ] perfetto ok cazzo ok è peggio
libri e peggio di prima
bambini aiuto vi stanno mangiando dei
piranha ma fantola toglietevi sta
calando l'acqua sta calando l'acqua
velocci aiuto che cazzo fai questo
questo questo no porca [ __ ] ragazzi
sta cosa stanno dove sta peggiorando
sempre di più sta peggiorando merda
merda merda si è fatto
ma porca [ __ ] quante sono al mio
volto a caso nel frattempo mi stanno
mangiando dei piranha se nessuno se n'è
accorto ma non importa o che ci abbiamo
fatto abbiamo fatto ci abbiamo fatta
veloce veloce e non salivo porca [ __ ]
dai dai dai bassi
1 ragazzi e bellissimo sapere di aver
regalato dei dei regali stupendi a tua
moglie per l'anniversario e poi gli devi
usare per tappare un cazzo di acquario
inutile e tutto per colpa dei bambini
che non si mettono mai l'editore ormai
l'affare non è più dentro e fuori dai
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
porca [ __ ] essi esci dalla sala giochi
si ma guarda subito proprio giù di corsa
devo riuscire a entrato di avevo
scavalcato c'era la porta ma chi se ne
frega
e tu sei stronzo ricordatelo oddio
ragazzi è stato è stata una cosa
traumatica e non farò mai più una cosa
del genere
direi che posso concludere qui
l'episodio perché per ora ne ho
abbastanza di polipi di merda tu che i
ragazzi se pensate che io sia un
giocatore di basket a dei livelli da
professionista perché è passato uno
squalo ma diventando strana la cosa
comunque direi che ci vediamo non
prossimo episodio ragazzi eseguito è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e condivido trovata nella
descrizione 106 a prestiti scrivetemi ci
vediamo il prossimo vinto bene ragazzi